ok whatsapp estate lo so pero i capelli
sono questi miti attacchi anche ragazzi
sui nuovissimi episodio di video
correlati i sei ragazzi aggiunge il
risultato partendo dal punto arrivando
dall'altro come sempre io prendo in
considerazione i vostri commenti quindi
iscrivetevi qua sotto per il prossimo
episodio cosa posso cercare di trovare
nei video correlati e vediamo se
riusciamo a farcela anche oggi vedo
tanta bellissima roba partiamo con una
roba normale da dei ducks ong alle
dichiarazioni del presidente conte
[Musica]
mettete da cso mirata e questa è
veramente un pezzo di storia è questa
[Musica]
queste storie ragazzi mezzo miliardo
divisa da te partiamo da questa vediamo
se riusciamo ad arrivare al presidente
conte è un po difficile secondo me però
considerando che siamo in ambito canzoni
quindi c'è tutta la fila delle canzoni è
in ambito bambini quindi non c'è niente
che possa nel punto più lontano da
blanda conte antonio conte sta dicendo
ma antonio conte allena l'inter quindi
non so come arrivare la dichiarazione
presidente conte proviamo a chiarirvi
state proprio forse era meglio rimanere
dov'era prima secondo me doveva uscire
dall'ambito bambini prova che quando ci
entri non so come fai luci planet song
knockhill tutto kills demo di 20 minuti
di allenamento cardio tonificante di
strong buy zumba come mi vado a inter
volare ancora di più però clicchiamo lo
zumba è giusto perché in qualche modo
passiamo al italiano che potrebbe avere
un senso o meno male che è mica che
capisce che sono italiano dalla
posizione che sono fugati arrivavo
all'italia fare cardio guardando le
dichiarazioni del presidente compì
quarantena el'abbiamo dai ce l'abbiamo
ce l'abbiamo ce l'abbiamo ce l'abbiamo
40 parola quarantena c'è la parola
quarantena c'è manca tutto il resto però
già abbiamo presidente dove sei
presidenti
dov'è allora piano economico piano
economico della regione campania piano
economico presidente ma no prodotto a
chiudere i confield aids ci siamo
impossibile che non riesca ad esso
impossibile ma basta de luca c'è ma in
tutto quel inviato dalle iene attacca
con te
fonte le dichiarazioni del presidente
con te l'abbiamo ce l'abbiamo
abbiamo tronto concia messo una vita a
trovare con tema la mia troppo
questo è difficile questo è difficile da
scottex anche conosciuto come ceo bacio
se io ti voglio bene a steve jobs
[Musica]
la semplicità è un'altra cosa questo è
difficile però scottex quindi si sa già
in partenza si come posso scegliere la
partenza fa le recensioni dell'iphone se
vado avanti dovrei trovare rob e magari
non solo di ceo ma anche degli iphone
quindi siamo sugli iphone
teoricamente avremo rimanere sugli
iphone vediamo se anche anche se si è
completamente diverso però c'è la parola
iphone quindi speriamo di beccarci la
conferenza di steve jobs
la recensione magica iphone nel 66
fantino quindi rimaniamo sempre la è
come passare la steve jobs senza andare
da top 10 frutti credo che non sia i cap
eccolo qua ad ora fa ecco forse forse
con galeazzi forse con galeazzi ci
avviciniamo un po più al tecnico e
quindi può essere che mi becchi e steve
jobs oppure marco montemagno anche marco
montemagno apple iphone serie che
poniamo la entrambe le galassie mi sta
salvando il culo ragazzi fa anche rima
da qua
mammamia iphone hicks unboxing da qua ci
dovremmo essere grazie a quell'orario
[Musica]
tutto qui grazie galeazzi
molto bene ragan date da dio le prime
due queste attenzioni grazie anche a
scottex perché effettivamente ha fatto
il video dell'iphone sono fosse stato
per quello ciao
ma questo non è semplice ragazza il
finale di oggi è molto molto molto
travagliato da ma mille panchine ad
eminem
[Musica]
ma mille pancina ainur apriamo un video
de jong barry non ha idea di cosa sia la
mina e panchine sono sincero arriviamo a
eminem e non credo non credo sia facile
pro proviamoci vado dal mio punto di
vista perché qua
teoricamente riesco sempre a
destreggiarmi un po meglio devo stare
attento a non cadere nella trappola di
seguire solo i miei video perché poi
diventa problematico però valigia
intervista giulia penn no dovevo andare
sulla musica quindi io andrei sulle mie
parodie
il problema è che kakà che non lo so
come prendere la mia parola alla quale
come ci arriva una parodia crossbar
challenge perfetto da quale dovrebbe
questo il mio primo video in assoluto
per views quindi d'acqua arrivare alle
canzoni no tutte cross balena una
parodia una reaction una parodia parodia
musicale non è che sto dicendo chissà
cosa parli a questa qua una canzone
perfetto peccato ragazzi siamo
nell'ambito musicale mettiamo quella con
famiglia che è meglio guarda quanta
guarda qua spe dove eccolo eccolo don
giovanni allora d'acqua teoricamente
dobbiamo spostarci sul la musica però
non italiana auto blu auto blu di shiva
perché da qua mi collego a gabry ponte
che fa le robe mondiali quindi dal
mondiale poi mi sposto eminem
da capri fonte quindi blu dai consigli
auto blu non mi consiglia blu perché la
parodia dei punt hellas che stupido
civ auto blu
e poi adesso blu da pd dopo la
international wine blues da veri è un
remix ma va bene dati questo ci
arriveremo a quello originale però poi o
no non è quello originale ma vedrai
comunque siamo lì perciò dopo 65 anni
l'ho trovato incredibile da qua la vedo
difficilissimo arrivare il rapper più
rossa d'italia del proprio veloci
d'italia eminem celo celo celo cacchio
oggi sono stato bravo non so come mai
non vi sia piaciuto chiudiamo questo
episodio parte mi sarei qui sotto nei
commenti che cosa volete che io cerchi
nel prossimi sono i video correlati e
noi come sempre ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza
[Musica]